[Music]
this will be a session on the trade-offs
between traders and synergies between
the short-term and long-term safety
problems so there's a lot of different
ways to talk about the trade-offs and
synergies between the long term and
short term here so before I define what
we'll be discussing in this session
concretely will have a short word about
work to really not be discussing in this
session which is this very common
framing of this problem being roughly of
the form well X is just a distraction
the real problem is Y and then X is
going to be something like algorithmic
fairness and Y is going to be something
like long term a alignments and
Catherine I never know her thoughts on
this yeah so we all sat down to have a
quick like preliminary chat yesterday
about what we thought was interesting to
debate in front of this group and what
we agree on and what we don't agree on
so we all agreed that we're not gonna
address the question of whether like
governance or policy solutions synergize
our trade-off because we all broadly
agree that if you're looking at
governance or like institutional
decision making about what's good to
deploy in what order that there are
synergies there and there's gonna be a
continuous path so we're gonna focus on
technical research when we say
short-term we're gonna talk about
systems that exist today we're not gonna
try and debate what's gonna happen in
five or 20 years in which of those is
short or long and then we say systems
exist today that could be like
reinforcement learning systems that are
running in stimulation they're not
necessarily stuff that's deployed in a
product when we say problem we
identified sort of a bifurcation between
a problem is something that's causing
harm and a problem that's something
that's not acting the way we expect or
were confused about in some sense and
we're gonna focus on problems as stuff
that's not going the way we expect or
confusions rather than concrete harms to
the individual or group people right now
and we're also not gonna tell anyone to
stop researching anything we think
research happens best when you're really
fascinated in the topic that you're
working on and feel really engaged in it
and
so we're not gonna like go around finger
wagging at anyone for recently they all
doing great yeah and we also identified
that there's a difference in framing
between well there are problems now and
those synergize with problems later and
what we can implement these solutions
now and we can implement those same
solutions later and we think both okay
so I guess like what where we found the
most disagreements I guess is to what
extent is near-term and I said to
research contributing to the solutions
to the long-term safety problems
would you agree there was yeah okay
and of course there's a question of
course like what are we then here mean
by short term and long term problems and
these concepts on the self creep fuzzy
roughly the they mean people when they
talk about and I mean about two
different clusters first cluster being
these like as Katherine has mentioned
earlier these technical problems with
the current or new future a systems
involving narrow a is these systems
they're harmful right now and problems
and solutions for this tend to be more
model specific examples of these
problems are as a properly algorithmic
fairness differential privacy but also
stuff like over sale examples or a bus
of the distributional shift on the other
hand we have safety problems with the
far future very powerful AI systems
maybe even a GIS they are we expected to
be harmful in the future and we talked
about solutions to these problems that
anymore model agnostic these problems
include a value alignment credibility
naturalized induction Larry's problems
we had explained earlier really well by
Rohan of course they're problems across
the scale and maybe this is not the best
way to split up the space of a safety
problems so and we are going to discuss
this today as well so I guess we're
going to start with the opening
statements first remiel okay so one way
that I'd like to try and put forward a
way of thinking about this particular
question what it turns on is when we
talk about thought Turner stuff we
typically can
learned about technology which is
available now and the question that we
find ourselves asking the questions are
kind of of the format are the problems
that we're facing now Houston traffic is
there something about the way that we're
currently pursuing AI technologies now
that we're gonna abandon these problems
later when we have better technologies
then we have different paradigms or are
these things going to persist so the
answer to that question is going to be
some determinants of what the relevance
of the current safety questions that we
are discussing ends up what relevance it
has for the longer term questions so
like in terms of this energy aside I'd
like to break down the answer this
question the question of our current
systems idiosyncratic and of the
problems that they're facing
idiosyncratic by answering it hopefully
every possible way
because I have absolutely no idea of how
the answer this question and I think if
any of us claim to have the answer to
this question we're probably deluding
ourselves so ok so is my current systems
I mean things like people learning for
instance or machine learning in general
so let's look at the possible answers to
this so one possible answer is yes
everything about our current systems is
going to be thrown out and we're gonna
have better paradigms later in 10 years
or 20 years or yes and the aga the
long-term Adi systems that we that we're
going to build eventually are gonna have
no relationship to our current
technology so if this is the case then
the answer for synergies in our position
for this would be one of be confusion is
that look we don't have any other way of
talking about these long term abstract
ideas unless we try and resolve them in
terms of current models and let's do
that as an exercise to make sure we get
our terms down to make sure we know how
to think about them and to effectively
practice for the case where we have to
deal with these in another paradigm in
another realization in which case we
don't that have to be the first time we
deal with on the other extreme side
there's the case of no that basically
everything about the currents this
is going to be the basis for AGI so this
is kind of like the AGI is deep learning
scenario and in that case then there is
almost a direct link between the
short-term problems that we face in the
AGI level problems in which case we
better think about them now in terms of
the current system so then this is point
in the middle of maybe this some overlap
but there's going to be some other
paradigmatic shifts and in which case
there is a lot of value in us trying to
figure out what actually are those going
to be those short-term problems which
are going to transfer over and to try
and expend the time now to figure out
what the nature of those problems are
and what potential solutions those may
be and finally there's the kind of
answer to this of will who cares about
what the answer that question is but
there's actually a whole lot of new
problems which surfaced as we start
developing the current AI technologies
new fundamental problems that are
arising that we realize are going to
hold even in the case of whatever future
technology whether or whether it is not
based on the same technology and these
are sets of fundamental challenges that
arise that that I mean I'll just say
very shortly are things like and I'll
unpack these we can unpack these later
of things like the specification gap
that what we asked for is not
necessarily what we get and what we want
is not necessarily what we asked for or
it could be this problem of
distributional shift that we build the
system for one it like aiming to resolve
problems in one space but then we have
to apply it in a different space or
another possibility is another potential
fundamental challenges just having
learning in the mix means that we we
understand one nature of the one part of
the problem but we don't understand the
rest of the problem and we rely on
learning to basically fill in the gaps
of our specifications and that means
that there is some kind of epistemic gap
between how we understand the problems
were trying to solve with our AI or AGI
systems and what we end up building and
this leads the lack of transparency and
then also the problems about robustness
which may manifest at the moment in
terms of ever sterile examples that good
man
in any possible way in the future so
basically whether these systems are
idiosyncratic or not the current systems
idiosyncratic or not then there are
relationships between short-term
problems okay thank you mate I'm gonna
go next yeah I disagree with this frame
on my model if even in even in the
extreme you noted where even if we
imagine that the deep learning path
leaves fairly directly to general
intelligence my model says that the
reasons why why those systems might be
dangerous is not so much that they may
be susceptible to adversarial examples
but rather this for a problem where what
you select for may well not be what the
system is internally targeting in the
same way that the human brain was
selected very heavily by natural
selection for its ability to promote
genetic fitness to get its penis into
the next generation and yet humans a
general reasoner do not you know when we
wake up in the morning we're not like
gosh how do I get my genes in the next
generation today our our thoughts and I
mean some people might I just not every
day
my thoughts are also based on all sorts
of things like how do I have fun how do
i how do I learn things I want to learn
how do I you know bring about fairness
how do I like solve this one math
problem that I have in my mind and this
is a case where the brain was optimized
heavily for one thing and the internal
targets of the resulting optimizer were
quite different so so you can imagine an
analogy in reinforcement learning where
you really you you train a policy by
reinforcement learning for some target X
and then the resulting system if it's
powerful enough to be a general reasoner
may well not be optimizing for X this
seems to me to be the core challenge and
alignment and a challenge that I think
is not very well expressed in short-term
systems because they sort of aren't
clever enough they're sort of they sort
of aren't doing enough reasoning for
those they're sort of really have
internal optimization targets and for
this become a part but preventing those
from coming apart and sort of
understanding how to have the internal
optimization targets match some target
of our choosing this seems to me to be
the core problem and it seems to me that
trying to better understand adversarial
examples or a bust missed distributional
shift I don't attack this for challenge
well I think they have some use I don't
see them as sort of striking the heart
of the problem okay thanks um Katherine
yes so one thing I just want a caveat is
that I personally work on adversarial
examples so my uh my examples tend to
draw from that but I don't think that's
all of what we're trying to talk about
when we say like short term problems
where we mean stuff were confused about
in current systems or like neo for
example works on interpretability so
with that caveat maybe one thing I that
I want to highlight is that you're
saying that systems future systems won't
be dangerous because they're susceptible
to adversarial examples will be
dangerous because
this mismatch between what we've
attempted to select for with our
training process and what it's actually
doing and well I fundamentally agree
that nothing we have today is doing
enough reasoning to come up with these
like complex long-chain optimizers for
other targets I do think the reason the
adversarial examples problem is
interesting is because it has a much
milder version of a problem of that same
flavor where we've attempted to get a
thing that recognizes dogs versus cats
in the way we've done that is we've
grown dog and cat pictures on it and
we've gotten something that is just
fundamentally not doing what we want
like it hasn't actually learned the
problem and in this case I think like
the strongest piece I want to try and
put forward is that these problems today
can inform problems we'll have tomorrow
I'm not sure that any fixes to
adversarial examples today will also be
fixes to the sorts of long-stay
optimizers or inner optimizers you might
be worried about but I do want to
highlight that and for those who throw
at my lightning talk I mean sorry to
interrupt maybe we get to define what we
mean by interrupts misers it was
mentioned a couple of times but I'm not
sure if our audience knows um let's see
better what's that
I hate that nerve we can forget I used
it it's roughly the thing with Nate was
describing not not according to me I
think you're gonna drop that for now
okay um but I was saying yeah but
examples of problems now I think are
useful to like inform what might be
problems later
good so we've got a couple of slides ok
so this is a slightly different issue
than the relevance of say adversarial
examples to long term safety but I just
want to address some issues that have
already come up in the conference like
in Tim Wong's lightning taught yesterday
and other discussions I've had so so I
want to say that in general there are
big differences between the
narrow AI safety issues and the
long-term issues the Adria issues when I
emphasize it doesn't mean the short-term
issues are unimportant and thinking
about this to be I really think that air
researchers have a crucial role in
thinking about the short-term issues and
that they would really benefit from
sustained technical work like the
short-term issues and not just like
policy issues or like issues for like
activists or policy people to work on I
think they were like rich technical
problems there so I just want to sketch
how I like one of the big differences
that I see between long-term issues and
short-term issues so in terms of AGI
that is going to be super human in
performance humans can't reliably
evaluate its actions on a sort of action
by action basis it's on a very near-term
basis and we can't just wait around for
the results of the AG eyes actions so
you can't just say well we'll let this
agent try and work on cancer research
and try a bunch of experiments on humans
and we'll just wait five years to see
whether they have any long-term side
effects because we know that the agent
is smart enough that that kind of action
could have very bad consequences so I
think this is a pretty fundamental
difference when it comes to comparing
like what we need for AGI research with
the kind of paradigm for training
algorithms that is really effective
today and so if we think of some of the
short-term safety issues where like
these are issues where maybe people are
actually being harmed today by
deployment of AI or they will be in the
next couple of years so there might be
like physical harms or in Justices so
autonomous vehicles so in terms of the
safety issue of autonomous vehicles
humans can recognize the errors that the
cars are making for the most part like
we don't need superhuman drivers from a
superhuman like autonomous vehicles like
if they were just the level of a really
good human that would be amazing but at
the moment like human humans can
recognize the errors that the issue is
not like how do you train the system or
what's the training data but more the
systems have very weak
models of the world right they don't
understand human drivers and how human
drivers have a theory of mind and do
reasoning they have like don't have an F
world knowledge to drive in a very wide
range of conditions but the training
method there can be the standard method
that we used to like try named erté
humans trying to get feedback from
humans have humans hand-tuned reward
functions things that won't work
fundamentally when we're dealing with
AGI and then if we look at fare
algorithms that are making real-world
decisions they're often that errors
these systems make are very easy for
humans to recognize and they come about
again because of like weaknesses of the
system it doesn't understand law it
doesn't understand morality it doesn't
understand causality and which features
might be gay mobile so I think that this
is like this is a really important
difference and I think there yeah there
are a lot of continuities so on
adversary examples friend like I think
the even though there are other issues
they're making deep learning systems
into safe AGI is that we face though I
like I agree with Nate's
characterization there are other
important issues there it seems to me
that ultimately we want AGI systems to
be extremely robust like robustness
becomes more important over time an
adversarial examples seem to me like a
very good way of studying that where we
have the amazing you know advantage in
that kind of research that we have
actual empirical studies that we can do
and empirical studies have just
historically been incredibly important
in area I think if you ask people like
10 years ago what would the adversarial
example problem thief and you're on
there's I don't think they would have
just would be able to come up with all
the things we've learned from doing
empirical tests
lots of people thought are these these
problems will go away easily it seems
like that the actual picture has been
very different so I think if there are
areas where empirical study can be done
I think that's pretty advantageous in
terms of making research progress so
yeah there seems to be some of this
agreement in regards to how
representative are the near-term
problems of the long-term problems
so Katherine you said you believed for
example the recent examples are milder
version of the problems NATO was
discussing can you maybe explain why it
takes that well yes so the specific
thing that I was trying to point out is
that if you zoom out and say we had a
training procedure which involved it's
throwing examples at it or saying words
at it or hand waving at it that was our
training procedure can we expect this to
do exactly what we want we already know
that with current systems the answer is
no because we get things that you can
change a single pixel on an image a cat
and it thinks it's a dog like literally
one thinks it looks like very obviously
not doing what we want and then Nate is
is is looking at sort of a problems that
would arrive with different systems not
necessarily just like an image
classifier like gosh what kinds of
training processes or ways of giving an
objective to the system would like cause
it to bend and do what we want and I
think that like being aware that these
problems already existed that we don't
have a good way of like taking them out
right now is like one is a helpful thing
to notice I guess I'm not necessarily
trying to claim but like fixes to the
change of pixel and the cat becomes a
dog problem are also gonna be fixes to
the kind of stuff I'm I also just wanted
to say that I for the conduct of this
debate I'm pretty convinced that trying
to talk about stuff we're confused about
whether these stuff that's causing harm
today is going to help us narrow on
stuff that's like more helpful to talk
about right now because you're trying to
like fix the fact that self-driving cars
are crashing
there are probably policy solutions
today that are much better suited to
that or you know you're trying to fix
like unfair algorithmic bail decisions
like yeah those fixes our policy fixes
fixes right now we refer to this like
the confusion research right yeah yeah
we expect it needs to have expected to
disagree I mean do you think that there
are any properties of neuter systems
that will generalize to long term
systems let me just respond sort of
directly to your take I think the
analogy does not seem
direct me like it seems like if we try
to if we try to draw a line around the
problem that I'm trying to point to
which I readily admit I'm probably have
not successfully pointed to you with my
flailing words but it seems to me that
we try to draw a line that includes both
the problem that you're pointing to in
this tensed and or the problem that I
was trying to point to in the end and
the sense in which image pacifiers are
not doing what we wanted them to do when
we when they are susceptible adversarial
examples and that we're just no longer
talking like it's just we sort of zoomed
out to a level generality where I no
longer I no longer feel this captures
sort of my confusion if you will about
what seems to me to be the core problems
so like for example let me see if I can
articulate it like this model I was I
was saying earlier where it seems to me
like the key difficulty is positing some
general reasoner to be optimizing more
or less for an objective of your using
my model is that you sort of can't
really start talking about this all that
much until you can take what Ramana told
me yesterday that then it would all of
the intentional stance in the sense that
we have a whole bunch of of nice
theorems which say that if you have you
know some some piece of matter that's
more or less acting like you can predict
the world and is more or less acting
like it and allocate scarce resources
successfully dissolve a variety of
problems then regardless of what's going
on in there it's it's a good predictive
mechanism to talk about it as if it has
beliefs and has desires is making no
claim about whether it has a belief X
file or a like desires Python function
or whatever but we can sort of take this
fast or like ah you know it did that
thing because
it had deleted it previous relevant
knowledge because it didn't think it was
going to see this problem again I'm
making no claims about the internals
there's certain types of systems that
will behave in such a way that this
language is descriptive and predictive
and my the sort of problems that I'm
trying to point at of like how do you
get like there there's this way you
could take the intentional view and say
we can ascribe goals and these will be
predictive and the problem I'm trying to
point out is the one of life when you
have a system that has this property
we're ascribing goals and beliefs is in
fact predictive how do you get it to be
the case that the goals you would
abstractly prescribe if you were trying
to get the most predictive described
goals match the match the target against
which huge brain day the target against
which piece collected it and my my basic
model is that an image classifier is is
not close to being the sort of thing
where this intentional stance applies
like I don't seem to have enough of the
machinery to me that it makes sense to
talk about it as having believed having
goals I just don't see a way to draw
that line I suppose so I would agree
with that on the case of image
classification systems that it is a it
feels like from a human perspective
that's a bit of a stretch but I think
you only need to go to the world of MVPs
and pom DPS and reinforcement learning
in order to make that kind of intangible
stance very natural as though just
routine you routinely when you see any
RL researcher talk about their work they
immediately adopt the intentional stance
when they show their agent doing stuff
they talk about the kinds of goals that
this agent has in within this complex
temporal decision-making some audience
questions at this point
so I wanted to throw something out
I guess all of you especially concerning
the near term safety issues with AI
systems um I'm a little bit surprised
especially I think having an engineering
background when I hear about the short
term AI Spacely problems then I mostly
hear about you know image miss
classification
right now we have I think a lot of
pretty complex automation systems
operating in the real world that are in
fact safety-critical they're in control
of physical systems in the real world
where if the automation goes wrong
something really bad happens they can
have serious personal injuries or loss
of life or it is the big material
damages and it's often systems that have
little to do with you know machine
learning classification they have a lot
of different moving parts that are
interacting with each other often
distributed automation you have anything
from I guess the self-driving cars that
we're trying to build but also existing
systems liking you the power grid or
nuclear power plants that are heavily
automated and it seems that and I'm a
little bit worried that we might be
getting a little bit of field myopia or
tunnel vision and we're looking at what
we're doing right now in machine
learning systems but we're not looking
at the much broader field of automation
and what they are doing about safety
with their you know currently existing
and very real very present you know
safety problem so I wanted to do you
kind of throw it out humans and if you
have any thoughts them out what they are
doing about safety should inform how we
think about the safety of our you know
increasingly intelligent AI systems
going forward yeah so I want to strongly
agree with you that I think that the in
as much as there are problems with
safety critical systems that are
currently deployed that like an
engineering product society integrated
systems view is like entirely
appropriate for and that calling the
stuff that we're trying to scope this
debate to myopic from that stance is
like a valid criticism in some sense
like in our
the preliminary discussion he
deliberately decided to focus what we're
talking about on like D confusion like
what are we confused about today and not
what's causing harm today and I think
those are quite different problems which
need quite different solutions so like
one thing I've been paying attention to
thank you know Peter Eckersley bringing
this up is that California recently
passed a law that mandates the use of
algorithmic systems in making bail
decisions this is like some sort of
linear regression making like life and
liberty decisions for real people I
don't study that but I think it's
critical and I think that like groups
like the partnership I and I have a role
for like addressing this and
coordinating responses to this and
that's very important I think the policy
and government standpoint these sorts of
decisions how we make them as a society
from a government standpoint is like
absolutely on the like set of steps that
we're gonna take to making similar you
know life and liberty decisions in the
future but that they are different from
what a researcher who's trying to
understand a problem is gonna be looking
at in their toy problems in the lab and
I think adversarial examples are a toy
problem in the lab and they have value
in that sense but if your claim is that
studying adversarial examples is gonna
make self-driving cars any safer I think
that's a reasoning error but hey I kind
of want Neal and hey or whine know me
[Laughter]
greatly person Nate nail was overriding
Nate in my brain anyway but usually to
talk about like their closest examples
in current RL systems that we might see
to like what the longtime concerns us so
I think I remember in the Kappa flag
paper you have like a step for reward
predictor module so you've got you've
got the like at the end of the game you
win or lose but that's not very helpful
like making decisions within the game so
you have somebody that has things like
who has the ball as it my team who has
the flag as it my team or the end enemy
team and like you might then get the RL
agent like learns to do things that get
you the flag which isn't exactly the
same as the end goal when you get into
whether that's like the same thing yep
okay so so I I think this is a good
point to go back to a point that Nate
made which I feel like is much of the
crux of the disagreement here which is
about whether the particular challenges
of alignment or how I would describe it
as also being specification whether
there it's well expressed or not in the
current deep learning and reinforcement
learning paradigm and whether like in
some ways is this a difference in
quantity or a difference in kind so what
I mean by that is we're basically in
this situation where we say look we want
we want X we don't really know how to
say we want X we kind of implicitly want
X we say we want Y we write down that we
want Z and we end up with the system WWI
then we end up with the system which in
order to get Z ends up getting W because
our expectations of what Z actually
means in mathematical language we're
still kind of fudging our way around
this and we don't know what the
consequences of those particular
specifications are so whether that
difference between W moves the original
thing asks the thing the difference
between W and X I mean the cycle
fantastic whether that actually Furious
or not and what the consequences of
those that missed bests that ultimate
misspecification are if it's already
present and it's already deeply
problematic in deep learning and
reinforcement learning like the example
adversarial examples is one phenomenon
of this case reward learning and inner
loops of reward learning using
algorithms that try to take very complex
optimization algorithms there are
complex optimization problems that are
like very fast reward problems and try
and enrich them and create auxilary
targets is one way that you end up with
behaviors that you're not really
expecting at the end of the day how bad
this problem ultimately is whether it
involves this I know we didn't define it
but in the loops of optimization or
instrumental goals or anything really
potentially like run away in the middle
that might really really really not be
what we want I don't I
we probably don't have systems that are
that dramatically bad that we end up
destroying ourselves when what we wanted
was a coffee that we're not in that
situation yet but we do have models of
those and I think that there is good
work to be done to explore what the
consequences are what the signatures of
these things are and what potential
mitigation strategies
return David yeah two quick questions
the first one is but the people who
think that working on short-term like
things were confused about is important
how much better is it have people
working on that who are thinking about
applying those D confusions who long
term issues compared with people who are
working on those problems just for the
sake of those problems and then secondly
when we talk about long-term issues
being very important and also short term
issues being in very very important
right I think under like both of these
things are through right we don't want
to discard them but at the same time
it's difficult
how do we separate out say something
that's orders that like if you believe
that something is orders of magnitude
more important than another thing but
both of them are very important how do
you like they that like prioritization
in a way that doesn't sort of minimized
it doesn't sound like you're minimizing
they short-term issues yeah I didn't so
the first one was is it better that
folks doing short-term D confusion are
also thinking about long term and the
second was how to talk about this before
minimizing concerns
I can take the first one I mean I think
the I think it probably does make a
difference for people to be concerned
with long-term issues so if we take
adversarial examples there's a huge
number of papers on this topic some of
them aiming at fairly practical things
and there are practical problems with
them for several examples some of them
aiming at like proving theorems doing
verification thinking about this in a
very abstract context so like what can
you say about any classifier rather than
just that particular neural nets we have
today so I think there will be
advantages in people going at it this
with the mindset of you know how can we
build robust machine learning systems
where we don't know exactly what machine
learning system is we need to make
robust and so we want to always aim for
a level of generality so but I think
even people just focusing on the
questions today without an interest in
the long term may still do really
valuable work yes I wanted to try and
disentangle a couple of a couple of the
claims and see what people thought so I
heard two core claims from Nate one is
that this problem which I would like to
call you know how precise is the central
problem that needs to be solved and
another one is that we are not in a
position to study it today so I'm
curious if well if I've characterized
that correctly and then if other people
disagree which part of those do claims
they disagree with and then I guess I
was also curious although I don't know
that we'll have time to hear Nate
justify the claim that were not in a
position to study this today this was a
final question I I think I'm not super
interested in justifying the claim that
word not in position to study it today
because I consider myself to be studying
it today
oh I'm sure it could be studied way to
other than what I do although I do agree
it is central and be studied then Nick I
think I can feel it not clear that it's
essential I don't feel I have a great
handle on it like I think that
evolutionary analogy is pretty
misleading like we're trying to build AI
we're intelligent evolution is this dumb
process so there's a lot that we can do
that evolution was not able to do so I
think like you know it's unclear exactly
whether this will be a problem if you're
working with deep learning type systems
I think we need to eat if you need to
bring the rest of the discussion to
lunch so I'd like to thank our debaters
for a really interesting discussion
[Applause]
[Music]